queen elizabeth looms large over the
british capital
seemingly every street are washed with
flags and bunting
for weeks soldiers from household
cavalry tasked with guarding the monarch
have been rehearsing their steps
the platinum jubilee is as much a
celebration of british traditions as it
is 96 year old queen elizabeth's long
reign
but in the 70 years since she became
queen
her coronation a year later the queen
and country have profoundly changed
back then many of europe's cities were
scarred by the horrors of the second
world war
and the british empire that once ruled a
third of the world was melting away
queen elizabeth would help shape
britain's new historic purpose not as
the queen of an empire but of a
commonwealth of multinational
multi-racial states and also as head of
a royal family that would in the coming
years become the focus of intense media
attention as the family grew so did the
challenges
the death of princess diana in a car
crash in 1997 provoked public anger that
the queen wasn't publicly mourning her
death while millions were forcing her to
break protocol and join the crowds
more recently the royals have faced
intense criticism over their handling of
racism allegations by the queen's
grandson prince harry and wife megan
while sexual assault claims against
prince andrew forced queen elizabeth to
strip her son was touted as her favorite
child of his royal titles
over the decades presidents and prime
ministers have been and gone some of the
most iconic figures of the past century
queen elizabeth consistently doing her
duty
i think she's played very well exactly
the role of a constitutional monarch
she's the most charismatic sort of
photographed most famous woman in the
world but she's also very enigmatic we
hardly know her and i think
being able to stay above politics but
seen as relevant and respected has been
really
important here in the twilight of queen
elizabeth's reign a gentle reduction of
royal duties
after the death of her husband of 73
years prince philip in the midst of the
pandemic
a time when queen elizabeth's words to
the nation have scarcely mattered more
we will be with our friends again
we will be with our families again
we will meet again
even as more more people question the
role and the purpose of a royal family
in a modern democracy there is something
of a coziness a familiarity to her long
reign and genuine public affection for a
woman and a queen who ties past and
present generations together
neve barker al jazeera london